Tunnel mode is the more
commonly used operation mode.
Suppose we have two end hosts, A and
B, belonging to the same company but
in two different local area
networks over the Internet.
If these IPs are tunneled between the
gateways of the two local area networks,
then traffic from A to B is
automatically protected by the tunnel.
That is, A can send unencrypted or
unprotected packets.
And before the packets leave
the local area network,
the gateway adds protection and
sends the packets to the gateway
to B's network which then
unprocesses the packets.
For example, decrypts the packets and
sends them to B.
The gateway of A's network actually
encapsulates traffic from A to B
by adding a new IP header that specifies
the gateway as the source IP and
B's gateway as its destination IP.
To make sure that the protective packet
is delivered to B's gateway first.
It also includes the IP's header
which contains information about
the protection provided using Or
ESP which we will discuss shortly.
The original packet now becomes the data
or payload of the new IP packet.